what's going on people we just shot
hawkeye and then we realized there was a
spider-man tv spot that we didn't catch
what is wrong with us it's only like 25
seconds long but you know it's new
footage so we got it we gotta uncover
what's going on there let's see what
they got and i believe there are some
foreign language subtitles on it not
american oh that's how i read them
confused when i see subtitles that are
not in english i go i'm not american in
america not american oh cool all right
yeah
don't understand but good for you glad
you get spider-man 2.
[Music]
does any part of you feel relieved you
don't really have to hide
everybody knows spiderman but my life
was perfect when you found out you both
like each other we get it hang out i
need my eight hours have you been
listening this whole time not by choice
whoa happy stuff here all day it is so
crazy down there
finally some privacy it is so crazy down
there
damn it there's gonna be just so many
scenes of them getting interrupted but
when they're just trying to have some
romance their finally intimacy where is
he he's a sleep apnea machine by the way
i have a sleep apnea machine
i haven't used it in a long time it's
been broken and my insurance has gone
through this whole process it's been a
few months it really affects my sleep so
i feel really related to feel for happy
in that moment man some people might see
that be like oh my god what is he going
through but
it's a sleep apnea machine is that
peter's place and yeah it would make
sense that happy would might be there
looking out for peter well all this
whole fiasco is going on with his
identity crisis but why would he be
sleeping out in the living room
would it be that's that's what was
making me kind of question stuff
wouldn't he be sleeping next to ant-man
i mean i don't think it's their place
because it looks like they're at an
office or something like that because
he's sleeping on a couch he has his own
bedroom yeah and happy is in that room
too so where are they hiding out you
know what it's probably feast it's
probably that feast building for that
building that we saw with the feast
truck outside of it and yeah and then
they'll get attacked when they think
they're most most safe right that makes
sense why would they both be out there
in the living room sleeping yeah
it does and it is like even though these
shots are kind of tight like it is too
sterile looking to look like their
actual living room and then sometimes
for the sake of comedy it makes me kind
of question peter parker's ability
wouldn't he be able to have a little bit
of a peter me he's probably got a little
peter thing going on down there was
about to kiss and there oh yeah but when
did his peter tingle go off so that he
could like webbed netted really quick so
does he where the head's coming before
you hear ned walking by yeah i mean yeah
it seems like peter's abilities are
quite selective in that camp in that
department and maybe his peter tingle is
just way too strong to notice [ __ ]
like he's about to get a kiss from his
sweetheart who it seems like he rarely
gets intimate time with but what's
interesting about these two tv spots
combining them together they are really
heavily focused on both mj and peter
though isn't that nice yeah to really
capture the relationship for a change
yeah i i actually want that to be a part
of this movie and i want to fall in love
with them and then feel afraid when
she's falling and all that stuff i want
that to actually hit you know especially
because they're dating in real life yeah
so i mean they don't even need to write
anything for that they could just let
the natural chemistry take hold leave
your thoughts down below this is fun
yeah i missed these i'm gonna miss these
this is gonna miss these can they stop
dropping tvs until the next spider-man
movie yeah where it's unlimited tv spots
again
and every trailer
all right guys hey we'll catch you guys
soon thank you so much for being here
subscribe click that bell
see ya